[Music]
this is a pioneering neighborhood in
Germany solar panels green roofs
pedestrianized streets for children and
low-energy housing built at the turn of
the century the eco district of full bar
is now home to around six thousand
inhabitants astrid mayor lives in one of
the 48 EnergyPlus houses on site
Lambeosaurus twin Damania a Garda la
shala and fuckabish aluminum is on
overlap FF history and people vataj yeah
come on Santi met with is irrational no
clash Ilona Papa Satya these homes
produce more energy than they expend an
exemplary case that the European Union
would like to see developed elsewhere
buildings are responsible for 40% of
Europe's total energy consumption some
75% of buildings are considered energy
inefficient to address this issue the
new law will encourage the renovation of
existing buildings promoting the use of
smart technologies such as automation
and control systems that will enable
buildings to operate efficiently in
Copenhagen this residential building
constructed at the end of the 19th
century has just been renovated with
insulation of the exterior walls new
windows and an efficient ventilation
system it now consumes four times less
energy I think it's a really good
example we have in Denmark for decades
been renovating our houses our
apartments because we need to lower our
energy consumption all major renovations
and new buildings will be required to
integrate recharge stations for electric
vehicles energy performance ratings of
buildings will be standardised across
the European Union
this will help optimize energy
consumption levels we have now given
Member States the toolbox
how to make their apartments their
houses more energy efficient in for the
future
you
[Music]